[Music]
guys
we're live welcome back this is going to
be
an incredible stream it's saturday
it's like saturday morning cartoons but
we're saturday morning rendering
guys i am so excited to announce all
this i mean it seems like all you guys
know in the chat already
but um i'm doing my first
contest my first ever contest and it's a
render challenge and it's a big giveaway
so i am very very excited i'm teaming up
with nvidia and p and y p and y
to do this whole thing with you guys
they
came together got a nice prize pool and
we're going to make something super
awesome i'm going to let a couple people
roll in
we got about 87 people in the chat um
i'm gonna hang out with you guys for
like the next five minutes and then i'm
gonna get right into it and we're gonna
dive
right into all the details what this
contest is
first off um how to enter how to join
it's gonna go for the next
four weeks all right um
and we're going to create some super
cool art together very very excited so
if you if you hadn't already go ahead
and go to the link that uh that pny has
made they did a really good job
on the website they put together a
landing page for this contest i'm
calling it parallel
dimensions all right and i'll get into
why it's called parallel dimensions
in a second once the stream gets up
we're almost at 100 people
i think once we hit like 150 i'll jump
right into it
but go over to that landing page that's
on p and y
and uh just check it out download the
template
okay there's a template that you guys
need to download
because we're basically going to
populate it with
whatever the heck you guys want to
populate it with
you can see my desktop right here
this is this is basically what you
should see you know minus all the
the rendering the graphical rendering
and whatnot
um you know it's basically just this
little setup right here it's a
looping animation 87 frames and
we're going to basically build out this
environment
you guys have four weeks to do so in the
coolest
most detailed way you can all right
we got about 125 people in here it's
building fast
um i think i'm just gonna get into it
so guys it's a freaking
render contest okay it goes for the next
four weeks this week
is the first week i will be announcing
the winners um i believe if i were to uh
check my calendar here in the next uh
i believe it's the fifth the fifth
weekend from right now
but um it's called parallel dimensions
all right and the reason it's called
parallel dimensions is because each and
every one of you guys are going to go
to the landing page that uh pny has made
and provided for this contest it's in
conjunction with pny
and nvidia i'll talk about the prizes in
a second okay
go there download the template all right
so you should download the template and
you should be seeing this
right here we got a mountain way off in
the distance and we have a character
here
in the foreground and the idea okay it's
30 frames
per second here and it's 87 frames you
might have 88 frames
but 87 frames is the loop all right
that's the perfect loop
the idea here is that all of you guys
are going to build out this environment
with
the coolest environment you can possibly
think of you can make it
um like a like a moon scene an astronaut
walking on the moon towards a giant
mountain
you can make it a lush garden with a
character going through
maybe like castle in the sky studio
ghibli kind of style
you could do um like a torn down
post-apocalyptic war-torn
city whatever you want the only thing
you guys have to
keep in mind well you have to keep a lot
of things in mind
but you you cannot touch the mountain
right don't change the position of the
mountain
don't come up in here and be like you
know the mountain would be sick
like over here i think that'd be cool no
you gotta leave it right here okay
um and same for the character all right
the bones and the skeleton they must
stay the same you can't take the
character and be like you know what i
think it'd be cooler if like you know
the character was like a little
closer and i saw it from this angle it's
not going to work
if we don't all work from the same
template think of it like a coloring
book
and we're just going to be cutting to
all the different pages in the coloring
book
but it's the same piece of art right so
i'm gonna cut together the 20
coolest renders and you know set it to
some cool music maybe add some sound
effects and post it as a standalone
video on this channel here
and feature the top 20 creators that put
in the best work
that really deserved that that spotlight
that feature spotlight right so
it's going to be cool because the
mountain is going to stay the same and
the character is going to stay the same
but the environment will be changing
around the character which is why it's
called
parallel dimensions right so you have
this one character moving towards a
mountain in the distance
but this is happening in a bunch of
different realities a bunch of different
dimensions because it's cutting between
all these different environments right
so that's that's the idea all right i
can get into a bit more specifics of the
details on stuff as we go
but i do want to talk about the prizes
alright
so let me pull up the parallel
dimensions
webpage that the pny team did a
fantastic job
putting together and let me let me just
actually grab the stream
here i'll pop this out here we go all
right
so if you guys have any questions on
what this is or various technical
specific questions
you guys know i have a discord uh server
that you guys can go to
and there will be you can ask in the
help section you can at
me um it's just at clint on my discord
server
um and there will be a parallel
dimensions
uh channel or like list of
channels where we can actually post our
work in progress
very similar to the weekly challenge but
this will be over
a month's time okay so if you go to the
landing page
you can scroll down you know get a
little bio who am i most you guys know
who i am
so you can skip all that what is
parallel dimensions okay
so i briefly explain it to you guys
but i you know the pa the page goes into
a bit more detail
here um but it basically explains what i
was telling you guys
but right here download the template you
can click this you can download the
template
and you'll basically have a folder with
a couple files okay so in this folder
if i open up this folder um
download winrar if you guys can't read
rar files right
open up parallel dimensions okay and
you're going to see assets
and in here if you have cinema 4d great
open up this same project file that i'm
working in right here it's just one for
one
and then there's an fbx all right so the
fbx
you should be able to open in blender um
or any other 3d program
if for whatever reason you cannot see
this mountain
sometimes the scene is pretty big
because the mountain's pushed back
pretty far
okay so for me i know that if i were
in cinema 4d under project settings and
my view clipping was set to
medium i'm not going to be able to see a
piece of that mountain if it was set to
small i'm not even going to be able to
see the mountain all right and if it set
the tiny i'm not going to see anything
so set your your clipping mode to large
you'll be able to see the whole scene
some of you guys said that the camera
was turned around backwards
in uh in blender you're just going to
want to turn it around to full 180.
the fbx can be a little tricky it might
be a little tricky
i think the head on the actual character
is flipped around backwards for some
reason
and i was trying to troubleshoot that
all last night but i couldn't figure it
out
the file will be updated early next week
okay
so if you guys have any technical errors
with the file that file will be updated
early next week but it's not going to
stop you from working on this because
most of this is environment work if you
can get this
general look right here you can begin
working on the contest
right now with me with with me here
today on the stream
okay so um
i guess more technical details
you know it's got to be two 2.37 aspect
ratio
don't render it at like freaking 960 by
whatever give me a 1080 by 810
uh full quality render you can go up to
4k if you'd like but guys
enough enough of the chit chat alright
let's get into the prizes
because that's the whole reason i pulled
up this page here
it's easy to get sidetracked on these uh
on these streams there's a whole lot to
talk about
so prizes what are you guys gonna win
if you win this thing now i first i must
mention
that the prizes are u.s only i know that
sucks for a lot of you guys i know
but it has to do with like you know
legal
whatnot um on the pny side
it's just one of the restrictions that
are that
it just has to be that has to be now if
you are international and still want to
join the contest you are very welcome to
join and still submit work you can still
be featured
in the final video the final montage
that i'm going to be putting together
um and you can still be featured by pny
and
nvidia because your guys's work will be
uploaded to this landing page
right here right but prizes
us only for the time being i apologize
to anyone international i know i have a
lot of international folks
all right but
to those of you in the us
first place you guys get an nvidia
quadro
rtx 4000 now nvidia they actually sent
me
a quadro 6000 and i freaking
love it it has allowed me to render
larger scenes
use more programs at once higher
resolution
8k textures and seamlessly be able to
work
as smoothly as possible so the quadro
technology is
incredible and they want to share it
with you guys as well
so second place you guys get an nvidia
shield
tv pro this is basically i'm allowing
you guys
to upscale with uh you know ai
technology
any sort of um you know videos it's
basically a streaming hub
right that you connect to your tv and
you can upscale
720 to 1080 1080 to 4k it also has
ultra hd so this is a super cool
product that allows you guys to um you
know consume all of your content in a
really awesome way
the most highest of quality
the third place prize will get a one
terabyte ssd and if you guys don't know
about ssds basically
ssds have no moving parts right they're
solid state drives
whereas hdds they have the spinning
discs right
the s the ssds will work a lot faster so
you can put
like your operating system on an ssd and
boot up all your programs a whole lot
faster
so that's an awesome prize and then for
fourth and fifth place just as honorable
mentions
um p and y they want to throw you guys
these 256 gigabyte
flash drives usb 3.1 super fast
just as a thank you for you know
putting in the hard work because i'm
sure there's gonna be a lot of awesome
stuff from you guys
and down below if you keep scrolling
you'll see more details rules and all
this goodness
and some work that you guys have seen
before and you can enter here
upload your files your final files 100
megabyte limit
so that was a lot that was a lot
um so
i hope you guys are excited about this
i'm freaking excited about this i really
want to give a shout out to pny and
nvidia for making this possible
and the reason i want to do this okay i
want to make something awesome with
you guys um i think it'd be really
really cool to do a collaboration
project together i'm gonna make one of
these myself
all right obviously i can't win my own
contest but i'm gonna
i'm gonna make one of these myself with
you guys
uh over the next few streams here
and really just push our creative
ability to the max
all right and we're gonna push each
other definitely go to the discord
server
and post your works in progress and this
is gonna be a fun month-long project for
us to do together
and then i'm going to compile all the
best work into
one awesome montage all right so that
is the plan that is the plan it doesn't
matter what program you use i don't care
if you use blender 3ds max maya cinema
4d
whatever as long as you keep this
mountain right here
and this character right here you can
switch the character out for any
character you want it doesn't matter
as long as the character stays in this
position moving
at this pace with these specific bones
right here right that's the whole point
all right this is gonna be fun
this is gonna be fun um i hope you guys
i hope the international guys don't get
too hung up on the fact that it's a u.s
prizes only apologies i know it sucks
apologies
but i hope it doesn't stop you guys from
making something awesome and working
hard and getting better at your craft
because i'm i'm there with you all right
we're going to do it together we're
going to do all this together
and it's going to be sick about to use
google sketchup though
dude that's hilarious i mean hey dude if
you can keep the mountain
and the character there like do it do
what you want to do man just
make it awesome make it look super cool
as long as it cuts together and is a
nice
match cut between all these different
renders that you guys are putting out
then it's going to be awesome
non-us prize is healthcare toby you are
absolutely correct
[Laughter]
yup yup
all right so guys give me some thumbs
ups we got hey we got soda monty in the
house
he is a moderator of my discord server
and he's also moderating the chat here
so thank you
uh to sotomante for for doing this um
yeah if you guys are good give me some
thumbs ups all right if you're ready to
go give me some thumbs ups and we're
going to get started and figure out what
the heck we're going to do
for this scene here all right we're
going to gather our reference material
and we're actually going to create
something in photoshop to give us just a
brief
kind of um layout of what we want to do
right because i don't want to jump into
this too quick start adding details that
i don't really know i want to get a kind
of a blurry
quick little view of the scene i'm going
to create first and then i'm going to go
for it
so y'all we got thumbs ups
we got lots of thumbs up heck yeah guys
heck yeah i'm excited for this
very very excited for this
aniket yo you just watched the new vfx
artist react
glad you liked it man super cool super
cool
um uh ceyron the mountain axes are not
in bottom of mountain
hey that's cool man you just gotta move
that move that axis down you know you're
probably
using the fbx probably in blender um
now what i might do for you guys i might
actually uh get a legit blender file
someone who actually has blender uh
darren i know one of our other mods has
blenders so maybe i can work with him to
like
get a perfect blender set up going here
but
for today as long as you have something
that looks like this you guys are fine
all right because we're going to create
some concept art in photoshop together
and make
basically we're going to sketch out our
plan for what we're going to do
all right yes you can use custom
characters you can definitely use custom
characters
the point is to use custom characters
all right this is just this guy's just a
placeholder
okay so obviously another note don't
move the camera i should have put a lock
on that
you don't want to move the camera um
so this character is just a placeholder
you know
um my plan i'm gonna photo scan myself
with like all my hiking gear and i'm
gonna put myself
in the scene and then i'm gonna
embellish it with some like sci-fi
looking stuff maybe some like uh
sam porter bridges action a little maybe
a little death stranding action you know
we'll see
um but i i'm gonna definitely change
the character and you guys should too
all right give the character hair give
them some pants
give them a cool shirt give them a
backpack make it a robot all right
it doesn't matter as long as they that
character is utilizing
these bones right here right
all that's all that i care about um
that way it'll just match cut between
all the renders when you pop into this
in this view i'm gonna give this thing a
protection tag
on the camera so we ensure we don't move
that around
alright so you guys are good to go does
the animation have to loop
um it should look like it loops the
mountain is going to pop just a little
bit
on reset but the character should look
like he's looping
or it's looping i guess um
the overall idea is that all of your
guys's
animations are going to look like
they're looping except
the background is going to change every
time i hope that makes sense
so yeah you can re-target the bones into
a different rig absolutely
um if if what you mean by that is
a different skin like you can change out
the character but the bones have to be
the same the bones have to be moving the
same um
as long as you have a character right
here that's walking towards the mountain
that's generally this size at this place
with the same walk cycle then we're good
all right
time how much time do we have all right
let me give you let me give you
a uh an actual timeline on this okay
i'm just pulling up my calendar just to
double check
so on this stream
we're talking contest alright next
stream i'm going to be working on this
going into detail on this
on the next stream as well saturday the
24th
the weekend before halloween will be
um a standalone video
and then saturday the 31st halloween
is going to be um the final
week to work on this contest right so
halloween
is the final reminder to get your
submissions
in because on saturday the 7th i'm
reviewing
all the submissions saturday november
7th
is the drop dead deadline all right and
if you cut it down
if you cut it to the morning of the 7th
you cut it too close all right
um i'll still i'll still accept it as
long as i can
open it up and watch it and review it on
the stream i'm going to go through
all of your guys's work on november 7th
and
and look at everything all right i'm
going to give you guys breakdowns of
what i think is good what i think is bad
and i'm going to critique everything and
i will announce the winners
the top three winners on the november
7th stream
okay and the fourth and fifth place
runner-ups for those
um for those 256 gig
flash drives okay
so november 7th that's that's the stream
where i'm announcing the winners all
right guys
so don't slack do not slack all right
put some work into this make it awesome
make this the coolest thing you've ever
made also which frame rate is the render
supposed to be at
it's at 30 frames per second
30 frames per second is the frame rate
all right so if you guys are using fbx's
in blender it might be a little janky
your character might be floating um get
them on the ground
your head might be backwards rotate it
back forwards
all right it should look like this all
right it should look
like this i'm going to make sure that um
come early next week
all right you blender folks will have a
file that you can download that you that
will
look fine all right um but for now
we're okay with this all right as long
as you can see something that looks
very very very similar to this we'll be
okay
because it's time to hop into photoshop
and figure out what the heck we're gonna
do
all right let's let's make this happen
so let's open photoshop here
i'm also going to download or not
download i'm also going to go to
pinterest
and we're going to gather a bunch
of different reference material
okay
so what are we going to do you can we
guys we can literally do
anything we want to do for this
environment we're going to build out
this environment in the coolest way
possible
and we want to fill this out with some
awesome art
okay
sweet
so over you know the last couple days i
was thinking what i'm gonna do
for my environment and the first thing
i'm going to do is
gather reference material in order to
you know guide basically guide my
decisions throughout the entire process
it's the the reference material is going
to keep me on a straight path
throughout my entire creative process
all right now this is true for basically
everything no matter what you're
creating if it's
anything serious you know for a job or
if it's something that you're like
really going to put time into and want
to make it look good
you want to gather reference material
all right
it's going to guide us on the creative
process so
i'm just going to go ahead and look up
on on pinterest i'm going to look up
swamp all right
and there is
not many pictures that give me the vibe
i want
i'm thinking of never ending story swamp
something like that never earning story
swamp yes
okay something like this
something like this so the cool thing
about pinterest
is you know it'll give you different
references
for similar images and you can save
these and all that but it looks like a
lot of random crap right now i think we
need to build out
our reference list and hone it in a
little bit more
um tom thank you for the super chat
brother really appreciate it
he says as a blender noob who wants to
try uh who wants to try this thanks for
getting us a blender file next week yes
i got you
i'll make sure you guys have a solid
blender file um
heck i'll download blender and do it
myself all right i'm gonna make sure you
guys are good to go all right
but right now let's gather some
reference material together
pc perf yo welcome
i'm glad you joined me live for the
first time i started this back in march
it's about time it's really about time
so i really appreciate it
um okay let's keep looking up swamp so
we got neverending story swamp
um if you guys have never used pinterest
before it's actually pretty sweet
so i'm going to create a new let's
save no i don't want to save it to door
hardware
let's make a new board
we'll create uh let's see
how the heck board
let's call this uh
parallel dimensions and we'll create
that
okay and i'll save this to the parallel
dimensions board all right and i'm just
gonna go through
and save images that i think
clearly define the look i'm going for i
definitely want this like swampy vibe
with the trees i think it could be
really cool so i'm going to make sure i
save this to
the parallel dimensions
board awesome saved
now it's starting to get a little more
honed in it looks like this is like the
one shot
by the way this scene is so freaking sad
i don't know if you guys remember this
scene or
have ever seen this movie but this
wrecked me as a kid this
oh god just looking at that image geez
all these ads all these fitness ads
it's like half of it is just like
workout ads
all right let's keep going um
dark swamp let's try this
ooh this is this is cool
i like this i like this a lot
so i'll save it to parallel dimensions
and i'm just going through and and just
going to add
up some stuff now i definitely took
inspiration from the game journey with
the mountain in the background
but i'll get into a little bit of the
mountain stuff
soon here um oh the
mad max swamp
is a good one
this one here you guys know this one
right
this scene from mad max
super creepy super swampy but it's got
the vibes i'm feeling
definitely so i'll save that
now i can keep going on this and i
probably will
but let me talk about the mountain real
quick so i want the mountain
to actually give us a
warm cast because of lava
so kind of like mount doom
a little bit like mount doom so i'll
definitely save this
um into the parallel dimensions board
yeah i mean something like this would be
incredible
maybe it's smoking yeah maybe it's like
steaming like this
but i like how it's like there's
basically like a uh
a storm in the background and you have
this warmth from the mountain but the
foreground
i think will have some cool like uh
swampy cool vibes right
and maybe there's some lights in the
foreground like
maybe there's a village some sort of
village in the foreground maybe there's
tents or something but let me look up uh
well let's do mount death
from breath of the wild
um is that the name of it mountain
death mountain death mountain that's the
one from zelda right
yeah yeah yeah very similar
very very similar this looks uh
like a good source of inspiration
world of concept hey is anybody having
an issue where the mountain is
flickering in or out or is not supposed
to do that yeah
you just want to change your clipping
size for your viewport settings all
right
so your viewport setting clipping size
might be set to medium set it to large
all right if you're using cinema you can
hit ctrl d
and go to your project settings scroll
down just a little bit
and under view clipping just set that to
large otherwise it'll look like this
you know
all right back to those references
um now you guys know me i'm all about
the atmosphere and the fog and all that
good stuff so i'm
definitely going to have some bit of
that like probably some low-lying fog
i will probably reference quick souls
rebirth
trailer um
they have a really cool i mean man this
just
this just looks incredible i mean this
whole trailer is incredible
um oh man
that is awesome i'm just gonna save that
i don't know what i'm gonna do with that
but that's cool
the whole point here is to get oh god
this is sick too
god dang shout out the colossus the
whole point here is to get inspired and
and get as many different ideas together
as you can
all right because we don't want to just
go with our first idea
we want to trial an error we want to
test all these different ideas
in order to sift through and find
the golden nugget all right and that's
what i'm doing right now is i'm going
through and i'm finding all this
i'm going to save this to parallel
dimensions as well
um this is a vibe
i'm kind of going for yeah usually i'd
say this to my fog
board but for now it's gonna have to be
parallel dimensions
oh man this is all such good stuff these
ads are so dumb though come on
um
wow all right so we were talking fog
all right we wanted the quixo rebirth
they have like a really nice low-lying
fog
that i like um i think it's this
image
it's like this kind of stuff it's this
like halfway fog that you'll see
this is just an incredible trailer if
you guys hadn't already seen this it's
amazing
there it is there's that fog you see
that that low-lying fog right there
um i'm just gonna save this whole
trailer
but let's look up um
death stranding
for some costume stuff
this is great that's so good
oh this is cool i'm
i'm saving that i think that's awesome i
love that
vibe ah that's so good
wow
yeah definitely save this we'll
definitely save this guy
let's type in uh like uh back
packing hike
um what would i call this backpacking
uh
gear maybe i want to get like the
biggest backpack i can possibly imagine
huge camping bag
nah these are all ads and stuff um
mountain
rescue maybe
oh interesting maybe maybe it's like a
rescue mission
ah okay okay okay this this is
interesting because this is when you
start getting into the story all right
if you guys can get a story
around your your render bonus points
alright so maybe
i'm gonna save this maybe it's
a one-man rescue mission and the person
they have to rescue
is on the mountain or something like
that okay
and maybe they're passing through a
village and it's someone from the
village they went
and they're lost or something and you
have this character going through
trying to rescue the villager that's way
way out
so maybe i'll try and figure that out a
little bit um
for a village you will want tents um
village tent
um
tp how do you spell tp tp
tp10
god these are all like fancy modern
traditional traditional tb
all right so for those of you guys just
joining
um i'm gathering reference images here
let's take a look at all the reference
images i have
um how it's been a minute since i've
used this
uh here we go
all right so i'm gathering reference
images for
this environment i want to build out
and it is a contest so you guys need to
build out an environment as well
we're doing this together over the next
four weeks okay
and i want this character to be walking
through a swamp
maybe passing some teepees
with some warm light coming from the
inside maybe some villagers
standing by and in the background you
have a volcano
right going off here and there's some
creepy trees and stuff going off into
the distance
um and i think the best way to do this
is definitely to gather as much
reference material as possible
because then we can really start
figuring out what the heck we're going
to do because we're going to come into
photoshop
and we're going to paint some stuff
in all right so that we can get a good
idea of what the heck we're going to do
so how's everybody doing are you guys
hanging in there are you guys gathering
reference material
are you just just watching me gather
reference material i hope i'm
keeping this somewhat entertaining but
we have a good
good bit of of uh viewers today i i
think that's really good that's nice
what's the theme paperback paper pags
asks
well the theme is whatever you guys want
it to be you guys are going to create an
environment you're going to fill out
this environment however you
see fit all right there's a link to
a landing page that p and y created
it's right in the description top of the
description of this video
and you can get all the breakdown and
all the info on this contest
and how you can submit your work how you
can join you're going to download
an asset pack and you're going to
basically open up this
in your 3d program of choice if you've
never used blender before if you've
never even used 3d before
consider downloading blender and
learning along with me maybe you could
win
we got some awesome prizes it's going to
be a good time guys it's going to be a
very good time
tenem is thinking of something space
themed cool um let me ask you guys i'm
going to ask you
do you have any ideas on what you want
your environment to be
go ahead and list them out and i'll read
them out maybe we can do a little bit of
brainstorming together
because at the end of the day that's the
whole point of this i want to do this
with you guys together okay
jacob i am running this contest yeah
it's the uh parallel dimensions contest
that um that i started with the help of
p and y
and nvidia we're doing it together um
so it's very very exciting very very
exciting
all right a floating city vfx wizard
wants to do a floating city that's cool
i'm down for that
yeah feel free to add as much stuff as
you want like don't move the mountain
around don't rotate the mountain
or anything we want to keep it where it
is but have some floating stuff around
it you know that'd be cool
um i think that'd be super sick your
character could be walking across a
bridge
that is you know in the clouds and the
mountain may be the only thing you see
in the distance
and to the left and right it might be
floating city stuff i think that'd be
sweet
a medieval battlefield that's going to
be intense very very intense
just walking through a bunch of people
fighting that'd be super cool
a wild west scene daniel wants to do a
wild west scene
i think that's awesome very very cool
lots of good stuff
on uh on uh qixel bridge
for you to download they have a lot of
nice wild west
themed elements render warrior wants to
make it a bob ross painting
vfx wizard steampunk metropolis very
cool
william blade runner inspired i'm down
i'm super down
tyler wants something like crash or
spyro those are some of my favorite
games of all time
yep william with the blade runner jboz
what's up dude
you just lighting it on fire just the
whole scene
um what else do we got
matt you want to do a world war ii scene
very very cool
yeah that could be sweet like some
saving private ryan something vfx wizard
talking about hogwarts denso wants
atlantis
jacob ooh a time-stopped rainstorm
that's pretty sweet
heck yeah
random rotation i'm thinking about
something like the fountain this super
cool spaceship thing
that could be sweet how about giant gods
valley battlefront
how about it it could be anything you
guys want to do i just want to make sure
you guys are clear on what this contest
what parallel dimensions is
what you can win and what's required of
you
um yeah just want to make sure that you
guys are all clear on that i don't want
it to be confusing to anybody
but i'm going to hop back in and let's
keep gathering reference material we're
going to piece this together in
photoshop in a minute
and it's a little it's a little
difficult to think while i stream
because i definitely want to be
entertaining i don't want to bore you
guys but at the same time
i really want to put thought into into
the scene here
so this image here
from mad max
this is a really good vibe i like
the detail here in the foreground
it's wet and muddy and
i love the crows i'm definitely digging
all these crows here
i think this is awesome as far as the
trees go they're very sparse but i think
maybe what we could do is get to a point
where
the trees start to open up a bit more or
not open up but
the trees actually get a bit more dense
and turn into something like this
so maybe the foreground is kind of like
this vibe
but then once you get to the mid ground
we get this chunkier muddier setup
with these trees and then it kind of
goes off into fog a low-lying fog
like we see in the
rebirth trailer
something like yes something like this
in the middle
see this fog layer on the horizon
something like that um
and off into the background we see
you know kind of stormy clouds like this
and maybe in the middle of this mountain
here so we have this mountain maybe
there's a storm layer here there's a fog
layer here
and at the top of this mountain
maybe what we could do
is have it peek out and look
something like this
this is absolutely incredible
and this is the vibe that i want to go
for because i i definitely want to have
um a natural
lighting contrast uh the blue
will come from the overcast vibes that
you'll see
like here and here this is really blue
but we're getting that cool vibe here
[Music]
and i think the warm vibe will come from
the actual
lava that's coming from the mountain as
well as some like teepees and like a
small village in the foreground i think
could be really cool
um as far as the character goes
it'd be really cool to do let's see
you know some sam porter bridges kind of
a character
i want to photo scan myself with all my
hiking gear on
and start from there all right um
and i want to add a little bit of light
sci-fi elements
to that i think this is too much on the
sci-fi angle
i want it to be just a little into that
sci-fi realm
um and i want to be able to tell
a story of a traveler like this going
towards this mountain
in the distance who is
trying to rescue somebody uh
or save somebody so that's that's my
goal with my render
in a nutshell
um nihal so it is um
it's an international contest though you
international
entries cannot win the prizes
um the prizes are limited to u.s only
um for a number of reasons uh
mostly like some like legal reasons and
whatnot
apologies on that i wish it could be
international prizes as well
but you can still join um if you guys
are from indiana a lot of you guys are
from india
maybe you're from canada um
you're you can still be featured in the
final video that i post
because at the end of all this i want to
take everyone's best renders the top 20
renders and
put them together for the ultimate audio
visual montage
and you can still certainly be included
in that when i post that on my channel
um and then you know you guys can also
be featured by myself i'm going to go
through everybody's work critique
everybody's work
um and you'll be featured by myself
pny and nvidia like that's fine it's
just the prize pool
i think there's just a legal thing with
that that doesn't allow
international prizes to be sent out so
apologies to my international fans i
know i have a lot of you
um yeah
it's cool we can still learn we can
still grow together so
let's keep it up let's keep up this good
work awesome where where did a nice
number we got
300 nearly 300 people in the stream
let's hop into photoshop and
build out some sort of scene
that we want to make based off of these
reference images okay
so i'm in photoshop here i'm actually
hitting f
to cycle between these different viewing
modes
um so
let's see here and this is a template by
the way that uh
or like some wallpaper that's provided
for you guys when you download the
project
assets on the landing page the parallel
dimensions landing page
you can you know download these
backgrounds and whatnot
so let's let's bring the images
our reference images into
into photoshop so i'm going to go ahead
and save out some of these ones that
i know i'm definitely going to use
all right so i think we can start with
with this one here
go ahead and save this
and we'll be assets and reference
and we definitely want this image here
we're going to piece all these together
and let's go ahead and grab
let's see i'll grab the breath of the
wild one as well
all right and maybe let's see
i might grab this guy
hmm maybe i i need a villa i need like
something
for the village
um last of us to
island
all right if you uh
if you are trying to stay away from last
of us two spoilers then
you might want to just uh chill for a
second i'm trying to find a very
specific
image here
this game was amazing such an incredible
game
yeah i basically like want some
foreground
some warm foreground elements
um let's see what would this be it'd be
like uh
like a medical um
pop-up uh what would you call this like
in mission impossible at the end
medical um
medical tense at night
maybe we draw these in we'll we'll draw
those in so i'm going to go ahead and
bring in
these main images here
and see what i can't build out let's
start with the mountain
and a pro tip here so if i erase this
image and i come back later and i
realize oh crap i didn't want to do that
and you can't just undo because it was
too long ago basically go down here in
photoshop
and with the layer selected you can go
ahead and make what is this called a
clipping mask maybe
a layer mask so click that you'll make a
layer mask and now
with the layer mask selected
specifically this little window
you can grab the paint brush and
depending on if you paint black or white
it will erase or
reveal certain parts of your image so i
can erase it by painting black
and then i can actually bring it back by
painting white
that way you're never losing work
right you're working as
non-destructively as possible
so let's go ahead and and
and sketch this in so i'm just going to
bring it down to about yeah something
like that
we'll bring it in here
and i want to paint black
to erase something like that
oh you see i'm painting black over the
image you want to select
the layer mask and then it'll actually
looks like it's going to be white in
this case no black yeah
so we have our mountain back there we'll
ease out those
edges and i want to get
like a general kind of ambience going
here
so we can pull up
our mad max image
and sid hey thanks for the super chat i
appreciate you man
it says clint be real with me are you
growing your hair out
if so good on you anyway enjoy the
streams man keep it up um
i okay i'm i was trying to grow my hair
out i still am trying to grow my hair
out
um but it's getting to be a little wily
at this point and i might
i might be giving up on the hair guys i
might be going back to a shorter haircut
which a lot of people my fiance
would be very happy to hear but hey it's
all right
it's all right
so i'm going to uh lower the saturation
of this image i think it's too blue
and i want that mountain in the
background um
let's see let's lower the opacity of
this
we definitely want our character moving
up
so our horizon actually is lining up
pretty perfectly
so something like something like this
i'm going to go ahead and
make a new layer and i'm going to go
ahead and darken
certain parts of this image so
actually let's duplicate it ctrl j will
duplicate it
and i want to do this as
non-destructively as possible so let's
grab
the the burn tool i believe
and we want to get the mid-tones and
just kind of like
pull those out
and it looks like it's looks like it's
just desaturating it
so maybe this is a vignette situation
right
so we'll make a new layer and we'll just
paint
a large black brush at a low
opacity over all of this
and it's kind of doing the same thing
something like that we definitely want
to get rid of this guy so i'm going to
uh
content aware fill this dude out i'm
going to select them
control shift backspace or no shift
backspace
make sure your content is select to
content aware hit okay
and he should disappear i also want to
get rid
of this tree let's get rid of this guy
and this will kind of just be like our
general
ambient kind of feel and this
isn't supposed to be perfect this is
just going to get us
a quick look at the vibe we're going for
okay now the black bars i do want to
keep that's why we're doing submissions
at
two three two three six aspect ratio
okay so i'm gonna keep these black bars
in
and i am certainly no concept artist
i'm not a matte painter i wish i was
there are some really incredible dudes
out there um
there's a guy uh eitan his last name
etan um an incredible
concept artist and i actually got to
speak with him
for a video i'm putting out for you guys
later this year
and this is just itanzana i believe is
his name
and he just does incredible work
definitely look up his work he's
incredible
i'm no eton but uh we'll do what we can
here so let's keep moving let's keep
moving
this obviously doesn't look right so we
want to make sure
we kind of just get the vibe
and we can paint these things out we can
just select that color and get rid of
that
we want a nice a nice
cloudy sky i think um
let's bring
let's bring this mountain back in just a
little bit
so that there we go that's why we do
this right
so maybe the lava is running towards the
city or something
something like this i think this needs
to be tinted just a little bit
so if i actually make this a smart
object
oh let's undo that
be able to say screw it tint it blue
just a bit
something like that
now these trees definitely we need a bit
more of those trees all right
so let's go ahead and reference
where are you at let's go ahead and
reference
our swamp images
so stuff like this like the droopy tree
look
is a good one something like this maybe
these kind of trees we'll save that
this is cool
so pinterest is definitely your friend
here um
it's going to give you a lot of
inspiration and allow you to
you know see different angles that you
didn't
see at first um okay so this is this is
interesting
this is kind of getting into that
village vibe i'm going for
oh man i just saw a freaking cool image
this looks awesome
that is so that is so cool
not the vibe though um so this is all
very busy
we want something a bit more subdued
like we're getting into the
realm of things here
so here's a lighting style i love where
the sunlight
is peeking through the clouds so i might
try and get this
look i'm definitely going to save that
um
this is a tough reference to find i'm
trying to find some like foreground
like huts
and i'm not quite sure how i want the
architecture to be i don't know if i
want it to be teepees or if i want to be
like you know
tense i think um
maybe looking up like death stranding uh
camp
what are those guys called what are the
guys and what are the bad guys in death
training called
i forget they're called uh
the guys who steal the packages
dude visual i am
so glad that you are going to be working
on this contest
the work you put out is always
incredible i cannot wait to see what you
do
um yeah really like this guys the whole
the whole point of this contest again is
to work on something together
because in the end i'm going to be
piecing all of the best top 20
submissions together
into one awesome video that's going to
be featured on
nvidia's website it'll be featured on
pny's website i'm going to put it on my
channel
so i really need your guys's help to
make this as cool as possible
um the the more incredible renders i
have
the better that final video will be
right
so visual i'm really excited you're
doing this because your work is
constantly incredible it's so good
um yes they're called mules
uh when is the last date i announced the
winners on november 7th
saturday november 7th that's when the
winners are being announced okay
um so you got to get your submission in
before then you basically have
a month
we have about a month to do this
all right the mule camp i think
i think that's what i'm going for
destroying um
mule camp
maybe that's a google death stranding
eel camp
uh like this kind of vibe like they're
not tepees they're not huts but they're
kind of like
medical tents
medical tent
like this is pretty cool that's pretty
cool looking
um iraq medical
camp
not what i'm going for um
yeah i feel like that's gonna be a tough
one to find
but it's cool so we need a character
here we're gonna have a character in the
foreground
with some cool backpacking
equipment so let's see if i can't find
something like that
so maybe we just find a hiker
goodness these ads y'all
hmm
all right we're getting closer is that
ben stiller
it is ben stiller
i basically just need like this but the
opposite
where we're seeing this person's back
so this is interesting though
well maybe what we do
is let's go and let's find like a
very similar image maybe
maybe we can just use this one here
and let's go and cut this guy out i'm
going to use
the magic wand tool quick select
magic wand and i'm holding space bar
to move around the image and i'm holding
shift
to add to the mask that i'm selecting
so i'm just gonna just cut this guy out
really quick
this is honestly the first time i've
done a concept art
thing like this so it's really cool
actually to uh
to take it super serious you know and do
it do it legit
so be something like this um so here's a
here's a tip
if i were to scale this guy down
and scale them back up notice the
quality loss
but if i were to make him a smart
object scale him down
and scale him back up you don't lose the
quality
so make sure you make stuff smart
objects
when you're editing them alright so this
guy
we want to shrink down just a little bit
and we want to make him
let's see we want to make this guy like
a little darker
all right so since he's a smart object
if i throw some levels on them
and i make adjustments it's a smart
filter so i can turn those on and off
hop back in and make those adjustments
so we want to
darken them up
to match this this little branch this
tree branch here basically so we'll go
to blue
the blue channel give him a little bit
of cool
coolness and
we'll just lift his little black levels
just a bit
something like that and i'd love to give
this guy
some lights right so maybe he has
a couple layers where they're just like
kind of like a bluish glow
maybe he has something on his backpack
so we'll do maybe like
i could be on his like on his hips
oh and the opacity let's make sure the
opacity 100 could be on his hips like
this
or something and then he could have like
uh
some interesting like lights on his
backpack like this
and maybe on his hood or something
it's very similar to death training
very very similar um you could also have
like shoulder lights or something like
that
i'm not sure if i like the head one
i'll get rid of that
something like that and we can give them
a shadow as well we definitely want to
give them a shadow
so we'll make a new layer
and
we can sample the color here i'm holding
alt with the paint brush selected
and i'll i'll sample the color there
right and then if you do
the bracket keys open the bracket keys
up
you can give him a little bit of shadow
there
that might be
too much let's see what's the best way
to do this probably a low amount of
opacity
and i'm just kind of stacking it and
getting a little closer
like this
so that way we have a character in our
scene
quickly as good reference
right for us to use i think that
actually i'm kind of impressed with
myself that turned out
kind of nice let's adjust the
the scale of this background real quick
i just want to
open this up just a bit
let's go ahead and clean up let's clean
up these corners tom yo
thanks for the super chat man much
appreciated and yeah dude i got you on
those photoshop tips
i know a thing or two just a little bit
uh visual yeah there is a focal length i
think i chose
where is it it's a 20 millimeter lens
20 it's all it should be all set uh the
focal length is 20 millimeters
so basically um
let's see if i grab the floor
and i just give it a bunch of
subdivisions
you can see that it's there's some 3d
movement
in the foreground which will can will
keep the the scene moving forward it'll
constantly be moving forward and
you guys will have a little bit of 3d
parallax to work with
um ice cream paint job
dude super glad you're joining this uh
we need
creators like you on this contest
because you are going to make this thing
look
super nice um
you can add you can add subtle lens
distortion here's the thing if you guys
win this and i start piecing this thing
together
and i need a subtle change i'll reach
out and ask for a subtle
change like hey take off the lens
distortion so it works but
do your thing just don't make it too
crazy i think some subtle lens
distortion is totally fine
um and santiago what's up dude uh
thanks for joining uh greetings from
mexico heck yeah man
much appreciated i hope you're enjoying
yourself
on today's stream guys this is ooh we
got
340 people right now
this is a good one this is a good one
bob gilbert what's up clint you are my
hero just learning 2d at the moment
exciting stuff
dude keep it up man keep it up very
excited for you bob
thank you for the for the kind words
joe does the foreground looping uh does
the foreground have to loop as well no
it does not
it does not you just need to populate
this scene
with uh an awesome environment that's
all i'm asking you to do
um change out the character just make
sure the character you use the same
bones here okay
use the same bones throw some new skin
on it
give me a different character i'm going
to photoscan myself and put myself in
place of this character
embellish the mountain make it look cool
but don't move the mountain around
and say oh it looks better from this
angle now leave it here okay
don't don't scale it up like this
we want to leave it leave it like this
okay
kanban 23 thank you for the super chat
much appreciated uh hey clint you and
all the people at quarter got me
interested in vfx and now i'm
uh studying uh university studying
because of you dude that is
awesome that is so freaking cool to hear
i'm so glad
um yeah keep it up keep it up
you guys are awesome you guys are doing
great
it's exciting to hear that you guys are
getting inspired by all of this stuff
and the work that uh we do over at
corridor so it's very touching i'm glad
that we can have a positive impact on
all of this
winbush dude what's up winbush
what up what up hey man we're doing a
render contest you should join
if you have time i know you're busy but
uh
we're doing a sweet render contest man
and i think you could crush it in unreal
i'm just saying
just saying
all right topher how many different
environments can you submit i mean you
can submit as many as you want
i'm pretty sure you can submit as many
as you want
you just can't win multiple times that's
it
all right so back into photoshop
we're going to build out our scene so we
can come back into cinema
and really have a a road a path
to follow when creating so we can save
as much time as possible
so the only thing i'm missing here is
like the camp right
so i want to have you know some elements
here
and basically be able to have like maybe
some teepees or something
i don't know in the foreground this is
so janky
some tp huts here
it's basically like an avatar there's a
the episode of avatar the last airbender
the end of season one
when oh man where is it no it's
i'm forgetting forgetting the episode
but there's a season where like uh
there's there's a there's a village
nearby
and they're getting sick there so no no
no no i'm not a thing of avatar i'm
thinking of cl uh
klaus there's that village in klaus
um outside of town where they're
delivering
presents to that um to that little girl
that village that i think is what i'm
going for
um can i even find that
klaus village
okay this is animal crossing um
yeah the art in klaus is just absolutely
incredible i don't know if you guys have
ever seen it
um but it is
pretty mind-blowing they actually use
some really cool
creative tricks to make their 2d
animation look like 3d animation
so maybe i'll go back to pinterest
and we'll look up oh that's cool
maybe there's like a water element to
this
we'll save this parallel dimensions
awesome let's look up klaus real quick
klaus
with an e uh
klaus movie
yeah so there's a moment here where they
go to a village i don't know if i'm
gonna find it
on pinterest because it's like very very
niche in a very small part of the movie
it's this character here i don't know
this character's name
does anyone know this character's name
this little girl right here
um it's the village where she's from
we just
do this the right way
um what is her name
okay this girl mar margu
yeah alright and then
she has a village
oh boy this is deep guys
it's like this
this is it um
that's all i got geez this tiny image
right here
hey yeah they're like
tp hut thingies
well we'll find it oh it's a sami
village
thank you waffle doodle thank you thank
you thank you
that's what i need to be looking for you
guys are awesome
let's just google that
yup okay yup this is the vibe this is it
this is it this is it look at this
yup
the tiniest image
hey um
should be able to
search google for this image
and we get similar looking images
all right this is this is close
i think i need to just try sami village
one more time
i mean this is cool i don't know what
this is
that is awesome maybe uh
maybe that's just in the scene somewhere
like that's pretty freaking cool i don't
know what that is like maybe
instead of like a village
it's these kind of structures
scattered about
that is super cool
oh another thing i want too is actually
some like
telephone wires maybe um
let me stay let me stay focused i can
get very distracted um
let me try sami village one more time
make sure
there isn't any good stuff for us zombie
village night
mongolian village night
yeah maybe something like this like this
is pretty sweet
and then we'll piece these together in
photoshop yeah this is okay okay
uh this is good
and maybe something like this that's
really tiny all right let's bring these
into photoshop
and see what we can do okay one two
three
four bring these guys in
so maybe we can go with this vibe right
here um
but maybe like that concrete vibe is
is better let's close these out
all right so let's bring it on top it's
very tiny but it's okay
and i'm just gonna go ahead and like
position this lower the opacity
and position it
properly
let's hit it with a horizontal flip
image
what is it edit transform flip
horizontal yeah
something like that maybe and we'll just
grab a large soft eraser
and get rid of those edges but i'm gonna
do it with the layer mask so click the
layer mask let's actually grab
the the brush tool make sure it's large
and soft the hardness is down to zero
and we'll paint black around the edges
like this
and then we want to come in here and
probably chop this up just a little bit
because
we don't want mountains in the
background we actually want uh
just the silhouettes themselves
so just with the lasso tool coming
through here
there we go
holding space bar to navigate all the
way back around
let's come in from this side cool
holding shift to include those bits
and i'm going to hold shift to expand
this a little bit more
and we can actually just paint it black
um another the other way around so ctrl
shift i will invert your mask and then
you paint the rest of that stuff black
all right and then we can bring the
opacity back up
let's go ahead and get rid of this oop
go back in grab that black brush make
sure you get the top of that
obviously it's too bright so we need to
composite it
so if we control l
and we just dim this guy down oop
no the image itself control l
and we dim it down
let me go to the blue channel and we
give it some
some blue
let's see
we want to remove the like yellow cast
that it has
it's like kind of like that again i'm
colorblind
so
i feel like there's some magenta in here
maybe
and then i think we can just darken it
up overall
it's those highlights really that are
kind of getting us
right and it's and it's a sunny kind of
situation so
but it's like the outskirts of town you
know and then on the inside we could
have
a warm glow coming from in here
um mobius yo dude much appreciated on
the super chat he says hey man i don't
know if you remember but i had the young
creator show
he said reach out on discord friend
requested just letting you know
great stuff um i totally totally forgot
i got so much stuff going on dude um
so apologies on that dude uh go and
reach out on discord again just
send me a dm on discord i'll see it when
i'm done with all this
and we'll see if we can't work out a
time because i love doing stuff little
interviews with people and stuff i think
it's fun
oh sotomante ctrl t and then right click
and flip
it's faster okay thank you
ctrl t right click fl oh yep
sorry knows what's up
all right so i still feel like the color
cast on this is off
so maybe it's that and then the
saturation just needs to come down
is that worse i can't tell
maybe it just needs to be darker
and then i'll just go ahead and
hit this a little bit more with that
black brush
very soft something like that
cool and then i want to give it some
glow from the inside
definitely want to give it a little bit
of a highlight
from in here so let's go ahead and grab
let's reference the
lava color
so i'll come in here hold alt and we can
grab this
it's it's really we're going for like
fire light so there's all like campfires
inside of these huts i'm imagining
so i'm actually gonna do let's do a mask
on a new layer and i'll just mask out
the insides of all this
this one too
and this one maybe we see like
some stuff on the top
oops holding shift to add new masks
and i'm going to go ahead and just uh
yeah color in that lava color
right and then you got a little
something like that you can duplicate it
and then throw some blur down
blur gaussian blur and that'll make it
feel a bit more realistic
a little bit of glow to it
awesome so there's just some subtle
effects there
um
now we want that like mid layer of fog
so i can come through here let's go
behind the houses
and behind the character
and let's see if we can't add a layer
of fog back here so i'm going to sample
the brightest blue i can
right here so probably like this color
up here maybe this color here
and just with a really soft brush
with the opacity set maybe the flow set
down and the opacity set down
let's come through with like a
all-purpose brush yeah that sounds good
that doesn't work
for whatever reason that's that's
annoying
um
charcoal brush sure let's try this
yeah something like that we'll set the
flow way down
and we'll set the opacity down
and i'll take this color and i'll just
give it a little bit i'll desaturate it
and brighten it just a bit
and we'll come through here and we'll
give it
this is the wrong brush let's be honest
let's just go with a soft brush
i'll come through here and i just want
to hit it with uh
just a little bit of fog
you know something like something like
this
to where like you can barely see through
and that will give it a little bit of
depth and atmosphere i think we can
maybe tone that down just a hair
like that yeah that feels good and we
can probably cool it off a touch so i'm
going to go
uh ctrl u which will give us
our saturation and we'll we'll just
saturate it just a little bit
but now when we go into cinema 4d or
blender or whatever
this basically the smoke from the
mountain up here is going to
cast a eerie glow on the surrounding
environment okay so that's definitely
something that we'll keep in mind i
don't know if i can replicate that here
unless i start googling some more
volcano photos like
having that uh that storm up there is
really cool
obviously we're beyond the bounds of our
image so maybe what i'll do
is let's go to google
and we'll type in we'll stay on
pinterest let's try volcano
and see if we can't get a large
detailed image of the sky of like a
stormy
volcano or something
maybe we're better off with storm
storm clouds
or maybe a google volcano
storm
man that'd be horrible can you imagine
being caught in the middle of this
what on earth dude
how's that even real this is terrifying
smokey volcano
let's be honest
this is what we want
that's so cool
um mobius go ahead and just at me in the
help section
on discord it's at clint
and i'll see it then
all right um i just want to make sure
there aren't any other images that would
work for
our volcanic vault yeah our volcanic sky
and i'm sure there are you know i just
don't want to spend forever doing this
with you guys
um this
here is the tiniest image i've ever seen
this is a little bit bigger
but for whatever reason it's just super
tiny all right um
maybe what i do is
tint the sky
in photoshop so i'm going to make a new
let's see
a new layer let's do a
photo filter
this will like kind of warm everything
up let's go for more of a red orange
i don't know if this is the vibe quite
yet but let's go ahead and uh
just paint the areas so i'm gonna with
the photo filter selected i'm gonna hit
control i
and that's gonna basically invert
control as
control i is invert and that will invert
this little uh
layer mask here which means black is
it's invisible white it's kept all right
so i'm gonna
paint white onto the black
in areas where i think
this would work something like that
maybe
um lower the opacity a little bit
that's that's still not the vibe but
it's cool
it's kind of there um let's lower the
opacity of this brush
reverse it and get some like blue back
into our corners
and i think what we could do is probably
have this
volcanic lava here be reflected
in our foreground so in this layer
i can probably come through i'll
duplicate it
i'll crunch it down just so this blue
is popping out okay
and let's hit okay let's set it to
screen
and that way it's really going to kind
of like stand out there in the
foreground
and i want to give it that layer mask
again
and we'll go ahead and hit ctrl i
so it's flipped and we'll paint
white back into the areas where we
actually want
that glow to be right
so we want that glow right
right down the center line
and we want to tint it another color so
i'll hit ctrl
u and we'll slide this
well i'll slide the saturation all the
way up
that's green i don't know if we're going
to get a white
or a let's cancel that and let's set it
instead of screen i'm going to set it to
add
and then i'm going to duplicate it so
it's really intense
let's take both of those ctrl
e to bake them down we'll set them to
add again
and i'll come back in control u i'll up
the saturation and then i'll try and
find like a white
oh green looks cool though
so i think here's what it is i think the
saturation just needs to come all the
way down
and
ctrl l will basically brighten it up a
whole lot
crunch it down
brighten it like that
okay and then i'm gonna duplicate it and
blur it
and maybe that blur
we will tint so maybe i can just uh
what's the best way to do this let me
try that again
we'll go to blue because we want that
orange look
so that's yellow so let's go to red
or no we got to go to
okay how do you make orange it's looks
blue
so we want that's yellow
red that's kind of orange
there we go
so i'll lower the opacity that's a
little bright
something like that maybe where it's
like kind of just reflecting off
and and maybe it's a little intense
so i can
get that clipping mask back and just
erase it in the foreground like the
foremost ground and then just have it in
the background there so it's before and
after like you're getting a little bit
of that glow
in the water which i think is cool
so how's everybody doing you guys doing
okay
we got 333 people up in the stream we're
making cool stuff
we're basically making concept art for
uh
a 3d scene that we're going to create
right here in any program you want and
it's for a contest
it's the parallel dimensions contest
that i'm hosting
and i'm very very excited about this
because it's a chance to work with all
of you guys
there's a link to a landing page that
pny
set up this is in collaboration with pny
and and
nvidia and we're giving out some cool
prizes
some cool hardware to up your computing
power
basically the top three people who make
the coolest render with this template
right here which you can download on the
landing page
link in the description you guys are
gonna get some sick prizes
um fourth and fifth place you guys get
some honorable mentions with
some 256 gigabyte flash drives
and i'm gonna compile all of your
submissions together
on november 7th we're going to announce
the winners and i'm going to compile
them together
for a really cool audio visual montage
that i'm going to post on my channel the
following week
all right so definitely go to that
landing page
and you know download the template read
up on the rules
join my discord server the link's also
in the description and it's
if you guys have any questions on this
contest then i'm happy to answer them
throughout the week throughout this
whole process we have a month
to make this look awesome okay
jay what up jay jay help me out man
you've been helping me out a whole lot
along this i really appreciate it jay's
super freaking cool
he's sneaking he is sneaking and
creeping in the chat
but jay helped make this contest
possible if it wasn't for jay
we wouldn't be doing this guys um
[Music]
i he he's just a donut he's done a whole
bunch for me so i really appreciate you
jay
um he's done a really good job
setting this whole thing up so everyone
shout outs to jay
thumbs ups for jay everybody um how the
rest of you guys doing you guys doing
okay are you guys gathering your
references and your assets and
everything
are you excited for this are you gonna
be participating
so if you're participating right
give me a uh
in all caps i'm participating
type it out in the chat i want to see
how many people are really going to
commit to this
render challenge who's going to win some
prizes who's going to have their art
featured i'm going to go through every
single one and critique them all
one by one on november 7th
and let's be a part of something
together let's let's combine all these
videos into one
and make something sweet nvidia's gonna
post it
pny is gonna post it i'm gonna post it
it's gonna be everywhere it's gonna be
sweet
all right vfx wizard is participating
oh my god silver gaming participating
david's participating
d uh devlin abhilash
qazi you will try you will try you must
try
um who else who else
varun uh bee
burke waffle original fri
there's so many people uh mister 400
paul soto if you don't have too many
exams
james you guys yes i'm so excited you
guys are all participating thank you so
much
it's gonna be awesome paper pags i will
try you must try
you can learn blender for this mr
charles is participating toby's
participating
sharon is participating jatin
chatting is participating
this is awesome very very cool
winbush maybe i understand you're a busy
dude
you just dropped your unreal engine
master class
on mograth.com so i get it i get it
you're bawling right now man you got a
lot of stuff going on
um silver gaming you guys are awesome
um and for everyone using uh for
everyone using blender
okay again i'm gonna have a blender file
for you to download early next week you
guys will know about it just join
um join my uh
this is what happens guys this is what
happens when you got a lot of stuff
going in your head you've been talking
straight for the last like
two hours okay join my discord my
discord
server my discord server you're gonna
join the discord server the link's in
the description
if you have any technical questions
about this contest
all right i'm going to answer them in
the discord server i'm going to make a
whole
new channel and actually sorta monte if
you can hear me right now
can you create
a couple different channels in the
discord server
like right now um the first
the basically the the sub genre or the
genre will be called parallel dimensions
contest
and then we can do like a work in
progress we can do a help
section um we can do a general
and and basically a place for people to
go to ask questions and show their work
and all that good stuff
um if you don't mind soda monthly
putting that together right now that'd
be awesome
we can organize a whole bunch of stuff
together and make it easy for people
sodamonte is the moderator one of one of
the moderators on our
my discord server he just does an
incredible job
we also have deering he's a good one too
man both of those guys really crushing
it
so i can't thank you guys enough so
i mean i think that's that's about
the most of it here um you know we
created
kind of the vibe we're going for
something like this i definitely want to
do something like this
now the left side of frame we can
probably just like
populate let me spend let me spend like
10 more minutes on this
and get an image um that i feel
comfortable enough for me to jump in and
start working in on uh
on in cinema 4d right
after that i'm going to go ahead and
announce the winners of
the video game weekly challenge you guys
had two weeks to put together
an awesome piece of art inspired by the
prompt video game
i'm going to go over those there's
there's also prizes for those winners
i'm going to choose five you guys okay
and i'm gonna
you know dm each and every one of you
individually on discord
and uh get you guys one of my favorite
video games
on steam hopefully you got steam or
something else we'll figure it out
just a little something small not too
big nothing too crazy
but just as a thank you for uh for for
winning and all the hard work you guys
have put in so far
all right so
did i line up the painting on my wall
with toolbar in photoshop on purpose
i did not but that's pretty sweet i just
realized this
kind of works out huh okay
let's see about adding some a couple
more things
to the image here so this is definitely
the
like the village vibe here if we go with
this route
so let me go through
and basically chop
out
these huts all right so i'll do it
quickly
just to get a vibe just to see if this
is
you know what i want to go for
these look like coconut roofs
all right we'll give it a clipping mask
and we'll invert it
all right the next thing i'll do is
go ahead and get rid of this with a
black brush
all right and then we'll go ahead and
soften these edges on the side
and we'll pop these guys maybe a little
further back
in the distance here
maybe something like that
and obviously we need to color correct
these bad boys so i'm going to
ctrl l
drop drop them down they're basically
going to be like silhouettes
in the horizon and we need to give them
some some blue
something like that
and then maybe go for a little bit of
desaturation
cool and then we'll give these guys the
glow
as well all right
so i'll go through the lasso tool
holding shift i can add to
the current mask that i have already
and i'll sample this color back here
we can actually add it to the same layer
so this will be our
light layer if i can find it
something like that maybe and we'll give
those guys
wait what did i
i think i added to the wrong layer
uh screw it i gotta do it on its own
layer
it's gonna be easier that way
boom duplicate and give it some blur
filter
blur
gaussian blur
something like that
so we could do something like you know
little little vibes like this
um
or we could go with the
let me just try adding a bit of shadow
to this
with a soft brush very soft brush large
soft brush
low opacity and we'll kind of just
paint that in just a little bit just a
little bit of a
shadow for these guys to sit them onto
the ground there
cool um so that's one option i'm gonna
go ahead and save this actually
so we'll do what would this be assets
versions
maybe we'll we'll do that versions
this one a now let's um oh definitely
don't need to save it and do jpeg
now let's try the sci-fi version here
where we have
these guys instead of the huts
so i don't know what this thing is but
it looks super cool
let's hide all this stuff i'm going to
save this photoshop document
just so i have it
all right
it's funny how as soon as you add lights
to it it turns sci-fi
all right let's try adding these
structures
maybe this is like way off
in the distance back here
and we'll give it that layer mask i'm
going to go ahead and just
bring down the brightness of this guy
maybe something like that
and let's go ahead and
chop it out i'm gonna get rid of the
background
let's see that's the best way to do this
grab that i'll go to the polygon lasso
tool i'm holding alt
to get rid of that little piece there
that selection
same for here get rid of all that
and with that selected basically what we
can do
is select the layer mask here in the
layers window
and colored in black
oh make sure opacity is full all right
we want to
invert the selection so we're getting
rid of
that background
okay then we'll ctrl shift i invert it
again
and we'll take a little soft brush and
just get rid of that foreground
hard line
cool and then
that feels about right ctrl d
to undo to deselect basically
all right it may be something like that
i'll get rid of this
so we could do something like this and
then maybe duplicate it
and ctrl t horizontal flip
put it on the other side maybe scale it
down
so they're kind of like going off into
the background
like this so there's multiple versions
of them and then we'll give them some
shadow
to ground them with a
low opacity large feathered brush
just kind of come in here and like
touch that up just a bit same here
a bit and we'll take this background one
and just darken it a little bit more
pull some of that contrast out because
it's there's a layer of fog in between
us and that
and then we'll go blue and give it just
a touch of blue
just a touch i think we can lose some of
the blue
on this foreground one so i'll just
desaturate it just a bit
so this could be an interesting vibe too
you know going off into the background
like that
so let me save this as a version
and compare i think i like the village
version a lot better
let me open up pure ref and see
which we basically can compare these
versions
um all right let's bring them in
so these are our two different versions
they're very similar lighting obviously
is the same i think it's just uh yeah
the sci-fi huts
or arms yeah i guess they're kind of
sci-fi
there's a light sci-fi to it but i feel
like i like this first one
um and we'll embellish the trees and
everything obviously when we get into
cinema
hmm but the stone structure is pretty
cool too
i think this will develop as we go but
this is close this is like a very good
path
for myself to follow for my render you
guys hopefully are doing something
different
now that's definitely something i don't
want you guys to do is copy this right
here i don't want you to do this and
submit this
you need to come up with your own
submission all right so that's very
important
very very important come up with your
own submission this is my path
i'm probably going down something along
these lines but man
how different can we make it if we were
to do a second version
you know we could do this guy on a sky
bridge somewhere
um with like tops of
skyscrapers poking out from the clouds
leading them to this mountain in the
background
that could certainly be a version you
could do a version
where it's just like a a super lush
garden
and you're walking towards a waterfall
um
in the mid ground and then in the far
back like
there's this giant mountain but it's
kind of silhouetted by
your trees in the foreground right so
you can do
so many different looks so many
different vibes i'm really hoping that
all these different submissions
are different different enough so that
like we can cut between all these
different looks
and that's the whole reason why it's
called parallel dimensions is because
it's a different character moving
towards a different mountain
but they they are basically in different
realities you know it's one person
walking towards this mountain
from all different times and places
from different people like you guys so i
think it'll be really really cool
so with all that being said i'm very
excited if you guys have any questions
the discord server there's a link to my
discord server in the link
in the description below and sodamonte
already did it
congratulations uh he he did a parallel
dimensions
little uh channel basically where you
guys can ask questions ask for help
there's general there's discussion
there's work some progress all that good
stuff i'll be posting
um my concept art in the work in
progress
channel on the discord server so you can
follow along we can all follow each
other's progress
over the next month leading up to
november 7th
when i basically you know go through and
critique
everybody's work and i pick the three
winners plus two runner-ups
um and we dish prizes out to you the
prizes are u.s only
but you can still enter and create
awesome art and be
um you know entered into the final
video which i'm going to put together
all these different submissions
and it's going to be freaking awesome
i'm going to set it to some really cool
music i might even make some custom
music for this
and in fact i think that's going to be
the case
so if you guys have any questions go to
the discord server ask the questions
there
i don't want you guys to be uh confused
as to what's going on
so this is the parallel dimensions
contest with the help of pny
and nvidia it's gonna be incredible um
so i'm gonna stop there for today all
right i'm gonna
keep working on it a little over uh
throughout the week
and then next week we're really gonna
dive into the 3d side of things
and and really figure it out and start
piecing things together and getting some
cool looks
um and then the final week the week
before the week of halloween i'll be
doing my final touches
on this on my submission um
and we'll get them turned in make
something awesome
so with all that being said guys i think
it's time to announce the winners
of the weekly challenge for two weeks
ago
it is the video game challenge all right
your your challenge was to
create a video game scene right with the
prompt video game obviously
and you guys had two weeks to do it this
time and there was some very incredible
work
i think the extra week gave you guys a
chance to really
hone in your skills and show me what you
got alright so
let's uh let's go over
these winners guys let me minimize
everything
get all this stuff out of the way and
delete this
and let me open up let me close this
here
all right so
the very first winner of the video game
challenge
the weekly challenge
is
john malcolm 1970 with this
amazing render dude i love it look at
all the detail in this thing man it's
lit
beautifully it's composed beautifully
all of the pieces that you made for this
i think you said everything was custom
made
just for this challenge
this is wonderful this is absolutely
wonderful man i think you did an
incredible job
you got your surface imperfections on
your lamp here
this is this is great yeah this makes me
just want to play some multiple games so
john malcolm congratulations on this
man you killed it uh once again
you are winning the weekly challenge so
you get the role
of challenge winner on the discord
server you'll be rocking that
for the next for the next month really
because we're going to be focusing on
the parallel dimensions challenge
over the next month okay that's going to
be the focus for all of us
um next up next winner
we have is job
with this super scratched up pokedex i
love it man i am such a huge fan of
pokemon
i played them all um when i was a kid
even into i mean into high school i was
playing pokemon
i was actually playing pokemon in the
middle of the field during a track meet
when i got called to the hurdle the
front line of the hurdle race
i missed it because i was playing
pokemon and i actually stood up so fast
and pulled off my sweat so fast that i
actually
pulled off everything i pulled down my
boxers and i flashed
everybody in the stadium it was horrible
it was very embarrassing
but that wasn't the worst part the worst
part was when i actually went to the
starting line
and i didn't i wasn't warmed up i was
cold it was a cold night
and i'm at the starting line about to
run a hurdle race hundred meters
and i'm like dude i'm not warmed up they
fire the gun i take off
i'm like okay i'm feeling it feeling it
hop the first hurdle
all right hop the second hurdle hop the
third hurdle feeling good
start to get passed by everybody start
hitting hurdles
knocking hurdles down dude by the end of
that race
i came in last place tripping and
falling over the finish line
because i was playing pokemon that's how
much i love pokemon
so job fantastic job here with this
render
um just a little maybe a little too
scratched up maybe a little too
scratched up
everything's got scratches man like like
everything's got scratches they're a
little deep
you know especially the map i feel like
the map would have more fingerprints
than scratches
but um dude i think i think you killed
it
i think you killed it congratulations
job you got the challenge
winner roll for the next month you'll be
rocking that so congratulations
um all right who do we have next who do
we have next this was tough because
i kind of chose seven people but i can
only choose
five so i'm really having to figure this
out here
um
the next winner of the weekly challenge
is final dearborn with this incredible
render
i had to google this to make sure it
wasn't ripped or a copy of something
because it looks so good
um but dude what a freaking job you did
on this this is juggernog from
call of duty i had to look it up i
hadn't played too much call of duty
but it is indeed inspired by a video
game
and it is incredibly rendered
it looks real straight up looks real but
he provided a clay render and materials
as required on these contests because we
don't want any cheaters guys
we don't want any cheaters i feel like
you'll be banned
if i catch you doing that so don't get
banned guys don't get banned
final dearborn congratulations on your
incredible render this is
immaculate i feel like i can grab this
pop it open and chug it back right now
so you'll be getting the challenge
winner roll
for the next month again because we're
focusing on parallel dimensions
render challenge um
so it's gonna be a good time it's gonna
be a good month all right next up we got
two more winners
we got two more winners
and this is a tough choice because i'm
looking at four people and i only got to
choose two
but i think i gotta go with the vfx
wizard
dude you you made you made a freaking
video dude
it's well rendered it's funny
it looks good you actually got a
claymation style
going with this your animation is solid
and there you go
yellow was the imposter this is from
among us
if you guys are playing among us i know
we play a lot on node
it's a really fun game i enjoy it i'm
not that good at it
but uh yeah the vfx wizard i think you
did a really good job on this man
everything's solid everything's solid
the only thing
i think could be better
is this shot right here this angle right
here
personally i would do
like this is just this is just your
taste at this point
instead of it's it looks like a cg
camera angle that's that's all that's
the only reason i don't like it
um again it's not bad it's not bad
i just think you could probably imagine
like you're in the hallway with that
character running backwards with the
camera you probably could have just done
a little 3d track
took that tracking data or just done
some general camera shake on a camera
that's moving back and tracking with
that character
it would have felt a bit more real to me
um the move you have just feels a bit cg
you know like the camera's just kind of
floating in space i know we're in space
but that's that's it man that's all i
got i think this is
really good really solid job so the vfx
wizard congratulations you got
the challenge winner roll
so the last one guys the last freaking
one
all right guys i think the last one
ah this is so tough
here's what i'll do i'm announced the
last winner but i got to give shout outs
to
the to the two who
who came really close just now but the
final winner
of the the video game challenge and
keep in mind all of you guys are getting
video games from me okay
because y'all y'all just killing it i'm
gonna send you my favorite game
but the final winner is mr visual
with this image here now
i do not hey hey hold on vfx was you had
your time all right you had your turn
just make sure you chill for a second
but this okay this image right here
visual
now i i do not condone drug use
um i do not condone the use of magical
mushrooms whatsoever
all right vfx wizard
it's visual it's visuals turn all right
so yeah i do not condone drug use i do
not condone the use of magical mushrooms
and i do not condone
the use of excessive
chromatic aberration in the corners like
this
but for this image it makes total sense
because mario
he got he got he got hit he got hit with
something hard
um you know it was probably from this uh
from this little vine guy
back here maybe he licked him right in
the back of the head
he got hit there's mushrooms everywhere
mario's having a tough day it's not his
best day but i like it i think there's
story
you got the render quality you got the
uh
you know you got the skills you got the
touch man i think it's really good
really really nice the lighting i think
is fantastic
your model is really really well done
um i'm seeing a little bit of uh
it's hard to tell is that a subsurface
scattering or not i can't tell but it
just looks
incredible it's a very very good job
so visual you're getting you're getting
a game as well as final dearborn job
malcolm
and the vfx wizard but before i'm before
i
call it quits i just gotta say shout
outs
to mdk because guys he literally made a
video game
it's called the king uh no the lord of
leap
and it's a video game where you can
jump from platform to platform and it's
super foggy
i don't know what he made it in maybe
unreal maybe unity
but um i'm sure you could probably play
the game too
reach out to him on the discord server
um
mdk is his name and he put together this
awesome platformer
i think it's freaking awesome
so freaking cool so yeah shout outs to
mbk you do really good work you
consistently do really good work
so keep it up i look forward to your
submission for the parallel dimensions
contest we could definitely use your
render capabilities
to make the final result the compilation
of all the results
be as awesome as possible and last up i
got to give a shout out to mr ronan
because
this is freaking sick i love this um
if you guys are bioshock fans you'll
recognize this
you know we got this guy i forget his
name i forget the character's name but
he's at the bar it was a long day
a really long day i like what you got
here ronan i think it's super cool keep
up the good work you came
this close this close
what could you have done to make it
better
honestly i think color correction dude i
think color correction i think you can
give it some vignette i think you can
crush the blacks just a little bit
darken up the image a little bit um
[Music]
give it a little bit of blur i'm seeing
some
like it's too crisp you know it's a
little too crisp
it needs that subtle
uh like camera distortion and it needs a
little bit i mean you have the noise
going which is good but
no actual picture would be this crisp
you know
i think it just needs a little bit of uh
of dirtying up just a bit more a little
bit of blur
it's just a little too crispy there um
and maybe more samples too i think you
can
could have gone with more samples i
don't know if that's render noise or
just uh
because when i zoom in to full i can see
a bit of anti-aliasing here
but those are nitpicks man you got
really close so ronan
you're doing good you're doing really
good
but guys um there is no there is no
weekly contest
this week because there is a monthly
contest and it's the parallel dimensions
contest
if you guys are just showing up right
now
i'm hosting a contest of my own for my
first time
with the help of pny and nvidia they're
teaming up to help
give out some awesome prizes to you guys
it's going to be u.s prizes only
but if you're international then you can
definitely still enter
and submit your awesome artwork we're
going to be
basically populating this scene here
with any sort of environment that you
want
um there's no themes it's just whatever
you can come up with in your head
okay um there's a link to the
to the parallel dimensions landing page
it's the first link in the description
of this video
all right go there get the info read up
on the rules
watch the beginning of this stream you
know whatever you got to do
download the assets you're going to get
a folder with a cinema 4d file and a fbx
file they're both
the same thing the fbx file is a little
janky you want it to look like what i'm
looking at here
but i'm going to get you a blender file
early next week so that you guys can
make sure that you're working on the
right thing but
first and foremost make sure you guys
are kind of sketching out your plan
gather reference like i did here
on the stream we were looking at uh
you know pinterest and google different
images that we pieced together
in photoshop to get us something like
this and
but i actually prefer the village
version that i put out which is
stand by
this one here right so i'll save this as
my background
set as background
i guess that didn't work there we go
right
so this is just a compilation that i put
together a little concept art in
photoshop
okay this will guide my process
throughout the
entire creation process of this contest
okay at first place you're getting a
rtx nvidia rtx quadro 4000 second place
you guys are getting an nvds shield
tv pro and then third place you guys are
getting a
what is it a one terabyte ssd
okay fourth and fifth place got you guys
a 256 gigabyte
usb 3.1 flash drives just as an
honorable mention
and at the end of all this i'm going to
be compiling all of your guys awesome
renders into one
loopable animation and posted on
my channel right here it's going to be
featured by pny and it's going to be
featured by
nvidia if you guys are international
you can join the prizes just can't be
sent
to you guys because it's us prizes only
but don't let that
get you all sad and stop you from making
something really cool
because we want to make something
together and we need all the best
renders to make the most awesome
uh what is it the most awesome
compilation now this was a video i'd
edit that part out
i'd freaking make it all sweet and chop
it up but there's a live stream you guys
get to see
the raw version
that's it that's it
go to the landing page the link's in the
description
um let me pull it up for you guys before
i dip
out here i'm very proud of how it turned
out
the pny team did a a fantastic job
here it is parallel dimensions this is
this is fun this is gonna be a good time
so download that template right here
download template and get started
i'm announcing the winners november 7th
on the stream live
i'm going to critique and review all of
them all right
and uh these are video submissions
your render has to be 88 frames okay
in 88 frame video because i'm piecing
together all these videos
um i'll probably
clarify the rules a little bit more um
as we go just to make sure no one's
confused because you guys have legit
questions
so i'm gonna chill for the next five
minutes i'm gonna grab a kombucha
and chill with you guys i'm gonna answer
any questions you may have on the
parallel dimensions contest
okay um and yeah we'll just we'll just
hang and chill for the next five minutes
before i before i go off and have a have
a saturday
so be right back i'm gonna grab a
kombucha
ah
matthew so the reason why the fbx may
appear to not have the mountain it's
because
you need to extend the your clipping
view
basically in cinema i know if i hit ctrl
d
project settings and i scroll down if my
view clipping is set to medium
i'm not gonna be able to see that
mountain if it's set to small i'm really
not gonna be able to see the mountain
and if it's set to
small or tiny i'm not going to be able
to see anything so just set your
clipping distance to large because that
mountain is really pushed back there
and hey i really really am excited um
that you guys you international folks
are actually down for this
despite um the the u.s prize pool only
um that means a lot to me i really
appreciate it
the prizes are super sick but the point
of this is to work together on something
really cool and create something
and focus on something
that will push you as a creator and
it'll allow us to actually create
something larger than just ourselves
we're gonna team up all of us and we're
gonna put all of your guys's renders
into one compilation with music i'm
gonna have a friend make music for it
it's gonna be super cool
um yes you have to submit an 88 frame
video at 30 frames a second
okay um
and what else
like i'm i'm like i feel like some
things are obvious to me but not obvious
to you guys so i'm here to for the next
five minutes to answer any questions
that you guys might have okay
can we download assets yes you can
download assets you don't have to create
anything from scratch
download assets um don't just download a
freaking full scene
and put your put them out in the
background really try and create
something craft something you guys have
a month to do this okay
if you cheat i will find out i will find
you because you need to
basically uh provide me a clay render
and
uh your scene file i need i'm gonna need
your scene file too
to make sure y'all ain't cheating you
guys cheat on this
i mean y'all cheat on this you're gonna
be banned from the discord server
and that's not good we don't want that
can you use any software absolutely
use blender use maya use 3ds max
use cinema 4d use a program that i'm not
thinking about right now
as long as you can import this template
into the three into your 3d program of
choice
you're all good to go
all right andre notice the character is
offset from the ground plane in the y
axis
is this intentional or an error it's
definitely an error
so let me show you mine
yep that's definitely an error and
sometimes that pops up so basically take
your character and zero it out
zero zero zero
all right that's not working
um yeah so now the character's too close
all right so
i think i'm just gonna have to update
the assets for you guys
as soon as possible i'm probably gonna
have to update the assets uh
as early as monday morning all right so
definitely
get working on this okay just know that
the character you're gonna have to
download the assets
and make sure that your character's in
the right spot okay
you'll be able to just take the
character copy paste take the mountain
copy paste put it in your scene
um apologies if there's any errors you
know we're dealing with computers
we're dealing with technology it can be
a little glitchy at some at some points
here
um i think we have pieces snapping out
of place because we're dealing with
miximo
data um but uh don't worry about that
don't worry about that for now he should
be on the ground but he should
also kind of be scooted forward so i'm
going to lock that in for you guys
with uh with a new downloadable asset
there
all right any other questions where can
i download the template for blender so
there is no blender template yet it's
just an fbx file
the the the uh the assets to download
are
on the landing page the link is in the
description it's that pny
landing page the link is like literally
right down here
um just follow that page
it's on the parallel dimensions page
you're going to see this you're going to
scroll down and you'll see download
template
right here this is how you get started
and you're going to be able to submit
from the same page basically
once you guys start submitting posts
they'll be on this page
so you'll be able to see all of your
guys's work from this page
my stream will also be up on this page
as well so you can follow all of my work
on this page if you scroll down all the
way down
all the way down you're going to upload
here so this is how you enter
name email you know your social handle
and then boom you can upload your file
up to 100 megabytes
make sure you guys read the rules um
rules and resources terms and conditions
go ahead and read all that stuff because
there's
details on like how to export what to
render and all that
all that good stuff
yeah so that's that's kind of it um
does it have to be only one character or
can we add more
you can add more characters but this
central character needs to be
the spotlight like you can have
characters off to the side if you're
walking through a crowd of people or
something that's totally
that's fine just make sure that this
character doesn't
move from this spot basically right
because we want it to be a match cut
between all the different
renders we want the mountain there there
needs to be a mountain
specifically this size and shape in the
background of every render as well as a
character
this size and shape in this position in
every single render
that's the point that's how we're going
to combine all these different images
together
or sorry all these different videos
together
of course hey of course you can make
your own assets that's
they're always of course you can make
your own assets
yeah you can add clothes and stuff you
can change the character model
absolutely just not the animation visual
you got it hundred percent
burke 30 fps 88 frames and render out as
an mp4
sure yeah render it out as whatever you
want as long as you can fit it within
the 100 megabyte upload limit
um if you guys win whoever wins i might
reach out to you
personally and ask for like a
uncompressed high quality version of
your render
so that i can take that and edit it
together for my for my sake
and put out the highest quality version
of this possible
um don't send me anything less than
1080p um
specifically 1920 by 810 that's how
we're going to get these nice looking
bars it's how we get these black bars
across the scene like this
you can upscale that to 4k
um or i'm sorry not upscale you're going
to render that out as 4k
as the maximum resolution so that's
going to be
3840 by
i believe can you do shader displacement
on the mountain
absolutely yeah texture your mountain
dew um you know make it look rocky
give it some snow um shader displacement
on the mountain is totally fine you can
add little
tiny details to the mountain if you want
to have like a
you know like you know little lights
going up the mountain or something
or or electrical antennas going up the
mountain or some outpost right at the
tippy top that's fine
but just leave the mountain like the
shape of the mountain should look like
the shape of the mountain throughout all
these shots
puzzle box i know this question is money
but do you have a
a length that you plan on editing the
shot in like will you only
display 88 frames are you going to loop
it multiple times i'm only just playing
88 frames
everyone gets 88 frames everybody gets
88 frames
yup no more no less everyone gets 88
frames
to do this can you go with any art style
or does it need to be realistic
it can be any art style you want
it could be anything you want any style
like it could be adventure time style it
could be studio ghibli style
it could be like low poly black and
white style it could look like samurai
jack
it could look like dark souls it could
look like
you know realistic it could look super
fake
it doesn't matter it's whatever you
think is cool
whatever you think is awesome
can you share your work on other
platforms like art station
i don't see why not yeah i don't see why
not at all i think that's gonna be
awesome like you guys should be making
work you're really proud of okay
so please yeah share your work it's
gonna be it's gonna be awesome um
and we're gonna feature it as much as we
can pny and nvidia
we're going to feature all this cool
stuff
visual this is going to be beyond
awesome yes it is dude yes it is
i can't wait to see what you guys do
burke yeah um can't wait to hear the
music such a cool idea through and
through i agree man
i'm gonna get a buddy of mine i'm gonna
try and get a buddy of mine
to write an original piece of music for
this compilation
um so i'm i'm really looking forward to
that
i'm gonna make sure it's really cool
toby should we avoid using um or should
we avoid obscuring the mountain with
foreground elements
is there a rough percentage that should
be visible
yeah you should be able to see the
mountain um you don't want to just put a
building here and just say oh there's a
building in the way
no you have to be able to see the
mountain in the final render
you can have stuff in the mid ground
like you can maybe like just
as long as you have like 60 of the
mountain visible that's fine
you can have like leaves on the side
here like you're cutting through a
jungle
like dangling leaves up top here but as
long as the focus is on the mountain
with the character walking towards it
that's the whole point
what's the last date the last date would
technically be
the morning of uh november 7th but i'm
just going to say dude get it in friday
night
november 6th because you don't want to
cut it that close i may not be able to
download your model like time zones
might be a little off
so get it in on friday definitely
november 6th
because i'm going to be reviewing all
the submissions and announcing the
winners on november 7th
qazi i think you could really make
something cool you said your pc kind of
sucks but that's why i said i'll try i
don't know if i'll be able to render it
out
check this out dude you can do a whole
lot with black and white just
shapes you can tell story through shapes
let me show you something
so there's this fight in samurai jack
very famous fight where it's all
just black and white
but i think that's a good a good example
for you guys
um abilash can i render in 1920 by 1080
you can but i'm going to crop it to
1920x810
because i want it to feel super
cinematic i like these bars
i like this feeling i want to get this
vibe right
so you can just know that i'm going to
put some bars on top
and bottom and i'll probably move the
image up or down
to best fit your
your widescreen render into this format
this is a wide screen format this is
2.37 i think format
1 to three 2.37 i think is it is what it
is so it's like 16 nine
this is one two three seven
or yeah that's confusing basically
this long part is 2.37 times longer than
this short part that's the idea 1920x810
alright any more questions guys
so should the character be in the same
spot on the screen for everyone yes the
character should be in the same spot
on the screen for everybody i know that
there's a little bit of jankiness with
like the character floating and the fbx
is like
the the things backwards i'm gonna make
sure that that's set for you guys by
monday morning okay
i'm gonna get a file basically ready to
go for you guys
um but download the one now download the
one now and get
get making your concept art sketch out
your scene come up with your ideas
and get excited about this guys because
it's gonna be freaking sweet
when will the blender file be available
yep it'll be early next week
as soon as monday i hope um
that's the plan yeah that's the plan
all right guys i'm a bouncer here
good luck join the discord server the
link is also in the description
if you have any more questions ask it in
the discord server okay
um and i'll i'll help you guys out but
in the meantime
good luck and i'm excited to see all the
work that you guys come up with
so thank you so much i'll catch you guys
next week i'll be working on my
submission
um obviously i can't win my own contest
but i'm gonna make something cool for
you guys
so i'll see you next week get working i
look forward to see what you guys got
all right peace guys